well if you've just heard the bite
Administration spends an awful lot of
time covering up actual crimes crimes
committed by their political allies and
their relatives but for their critics
there is no such Mercy For The First
Time in our history the government has
begun to arrest people for saying things
the White House doesn't like that's the
end of the first amendment speech that's
been protected for centuries in the
United States is no longer protected
it's now a criminal act
we've told you about the grotesquely
unconstitutional prosecution and then
conviction of Douglas Mackey the doj is
trying to send Mackie to prison for a
decade for making fun of Hillary
Clinton's voters on Twitter
the media barely report the story they
don't seem to care at all they seem to
endorse it no one in Congress is
meaningfully pushed back against it so
this trend continues the latest group of
Americans Define their constitutionally
protected opinions become felonies are
believe it or not
an organization of black nationalist
left Wingers who opposed the war in
Ukraine
the doj has just charged many in this
group was seeking to quote so Discord
spread pro-russia propaganda and
interfere in elections within the United
States
now there's no evidence to interfere
with any election you're allowed to be
pro-russia you're allowed to be Pro
anything you want in the United States
saying things that government doesn't
like having unfashionable opinions or
opinions that are out of step with Joe
Biden's opinions that is not a crime
you can spread it pro-russia propaganda
if you want to you can spread
anti-russia propaganda if you want to
you can say whatever you want
but not anymore
according to the indictment the
criminals in question quote wrote
articles that contained Russian
propaganda and disinformation huh
they also gave speeches and posted
videos that annoyed the state department
here's one of them
there's a discussion about Russian
military border uh build up on this
border with Ukraine and how this
represents a terrible threat uh uh to
Ukraine by uh by Russians but there is
no acknowledgment of the history that
took us to this place how the US
overthrew uh uh participated in
facilitating overthrow of a government
in Ukraine that was friendly to the
Soviet Union nor does it talk about the
history of this relationship between
Ukraine and and Russia this is an
ongoing aggression it did not just uh
it's all it's been going on for a while
but the U.S government uh uh relies on
the ignorance of of the people in this
country and much of the world that's
facilitated by people like Zuckerberg
so forever it's worth we're not really
sure who that guy is we know he's
American pretty sure that on a lot of
issues we likely would not agree with
him a lot of what he just said in that
video seems to be true but even if it
weren't true even if he was wrong
it would still be constitutionally
protected speech in a free country which
we had until recently you were allowed
by definition to have dumb opinions most
of us do
but not anymore so that man you just saw
is facing 10 years behind bars
for expressing views about Ukraine that
the bite Administration doesn't want to
hear
that's terrifying does no one else think
that's terrifying it is terrifying and
to that man's credit whoever he is he
saw it coming here he is at a rally last
month
they have declared
that black people are so
spit that it takes Russians to tell us
that we are on press I have never known
a moment
black freedom for my entire life I've
never read of a moment since the
beginning of a colonial mortal
production where black people have been
free
and yet they're saying that we are
working we are agents of some foreign
power because we say black people must
be free
okay again we're not defending that guy
because we agree with all of his views
we probably don't that is totally
irrelevant whether you agree with what
someone is saying has nothing to do with
his right to say it Americans are
allowed to say what they think is true
period
if they take that right away you are no
longer a citizen you are a slave
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight